ah well let's find out if labour are
willing to operate off a news story i'm
joined now by the shadow attorney
general emily thornbury good to see you
this morning with thornbury um what what
do you make of all of it i mean we we
have not yet had anything from downing
street to challenge the detail in the
telegraph report on that basis i think
you and many others myself included are
taking it at face value what do you make
of it
i think when i first heard it it
actually took quite a long time for me
to just get over the emotion that i felt
because i thought about her majesty the
next day
and the way in which she was leading the
country and behaving in such a
thoroughly decent way in which she
always does and she has always
i think in many ways embodied the
suffering that we have
had over as a country you know whether
it was in the second world war when she
was out in the east end you know and now
when we've had this collective trauma
from covert and the way in which she
behaved in such a proper
way in a way which makes us all so proud
and you think of that and you compare it
with what was going on in downing street
where there had been a culture that had
been set
over the time of the pandemic where the
prime minister made it perfectly clear
that he was perfectly all right about
this you know and and frankly we would
not have been seeing these parties not
just one party but two parties in one
night if they really thought that the
prime minister didn't approve or
wouldn't have been all right about it
but the point is is that the culture was
set by the prime minister his
responsibility and for the only thing
that you have heard from number 10
downing street is that their defense was
oh well the prime minister wasn't there
so what so what you know he is in charge
of downing street he is in charge of the
government that is how they were
behaving they were having djs in the
basement they were there were grown men
playing on swings they were sending out
suitcases for more booze the night
before her majesty was doing the right
thing and having a funeral with a very
few people where she was completely on
her own because that's what the rules
said she was doing the right thing i
don't often say but i did say it to
damien hines this morning i'd had a
degree of sympathy for him they did
human sacrifice put up by downing
straight in front of the cameras this
morning but one thing that he did make
clear was in his view that this would be
looked at by sue gray we will need to
get that confirmed i imagine but but
between now and the point at which she
reports what more can opposition parties
like labour do to to to to cast any
further lightning or are you simply just
waiting for the sunday papers
i tell you what we're waiting for we're
waiting for the prime minister to look
into his heart and soul
and decide whether or not he has a scrap
of human decency in him because if he
does he will resign how the hell can he
possibly expect to go before her majesty
again at a weekly audience and be able
to look her in the eye and pretend that
everything is all right because
everything is not all right
the one thing he should be saying to her
majesty is i am profoundly sorry
and i resign that's what he should do
and it's actually up to him at the
moment of course what we're waiting for
is we're waiting for sue grey's inquiry
to come out and hopefully it will finish
you know the end of next week you know
but
you know the poor woman she must be
right at the end of you know doing her
inquiry and then another party faith
then and sugray's ability to to carry
out this inquiry properly i mean you
know the one fact that everyone needs to
bear in mind when talking about sue grey
is that she was appointed to head this
inquiry by the prime
exactly and she's a civil servant and
this idea that she's independent or in
some way has a quasi-judicial role is
obviously not but we are where we are
i'm a practical pragmatic politician at
the moment we have an inquiry going on
by sugree she needs to do everything she
can and
staff at number 10 need to be honest
with her and give her access to their
phones and their messages and not be
wiping their whatsapp messages as has
been suggested might be happening we
need to make sure that doesn't happen so
she gets full access to all the
information is able to come to some
conclusions once she has done that then
we would expect the met to have a look
at it and frankly if there have been
crimes committed we would expect there
to be prosecutions but in the meantime
the timetable is completely different
for for the prime minister the prime
minister can today and should today
resign can can we talk briefly though um
about barry gardner yeah the proximity
that you know agents of the chinese
intelligence apparatus came to you know
the front line of
opposition politics and all of this i
mean despite the somewhat czarist beard
i mean the the sense that the the
allegation is not necessarily that mr
gardner was you know some kind of
conservative sorry some sort of chinese
communist party stooge but
was he well advised and continuing to
take such significant sums of money from
someone that he was so concerned about
he had not won but multiple
conversations with the security services
so i think that it's i mean you see this
woman and and she seems to have had
access to david cameron she seems to
have been given an award by theresa may
and i think that what it one of the
lessons that we learned from this is how
easy it is for people to weedle their
way into westminster politics and to get
access to to to to all kinds of figures
um and and yes
what we shouldn't do is assume that
someone else has done the checks you
know and i think that if she was thought
to be a chinese asset then clearly what
the security center would have been good
if the security services have been able
to say that in a very clear way
to hire her son then
i don't know what the conversation was
between barry gardner and the security
services but i i i'm assuming that if
they had they had uh told him that she
was a chinese asset then that would have
been it
it doesn't look like mr garner would be
bouncing back to the very front of
opposition politics any time soon though
will it
brag gardner is uh is a long-standing uh
colleague and comrade of mine indeed i
wonder just before we let you go i
wonder if we can talk just just just
briefly about prince andrew um no longer
um his royal highness uh
the duke what do you make of all of that
i mean clearly and this may well go to
what we were talking about earlier on
the queen has an awful lot on her plate
at the moment but that must have been a
painful decision
i just
i can't even imagine what it must be
like her at the moment i mean it's just
difficult isn't it one thing after
another after another but i think that
she has been well advised i think this
is the right thing to do and i think
that prince andrew has to
um you know in whatever way make
whatever decisions he thinks is right
for him um
but should do so as a private citizen
but i think probably more than anything
else i think of the potential victims of
uh of this uh of this ring okay
which i can i completely get but is this
the point at which and he has certainly
been sidelined from public life uh for
for quite some time now but is this the
point at which prince andrew disappears
into the long grass
well i don't know i mean i'm assuming
that he that he's now a private citizen
and we just have to wait and see what
happens with this court case but as i
say we must never lose sight of the
victims in this indeed emily thornbury
great to have you in the studio this
morning thanks for joining us